I'm involved as a defense attorney this
time it's a little different you're
about to see a case in which both of us
you and I are directly involved among
other things this case is about dreams
there's a funny thing about dreams most
of them are based on reality then of
course there's the dream it turns into a
nightmare there are many solutions to
the crimes you will see committed some
more obvious than others it will be
interesting to see how many you become
aware of in the following story the case
of Midsummer's nightmare in her backyard
and in her undisturbed world of dolls
and things Julie Anderson prepares her
favorite doll for a dip in the pool
inside her house Julie's parents are
bustling about preparing a picnic lunch
for the beach and in a few moments mrs.
Anderson will be calling Julie to get
into the car
it's a Sunday
with a delicious promise of a
comfortably warm and peaceful afternoon
Julie Julie come on we're ready to go
the Andersons often pack a lunch and
take a drive to a favorite Beach of
theirs just outside the city where they
can relax and enjoy themselves together
it's as the Sunday should be
[Music]
[Applause]
days as glorious as these Julie will
remember for a lifetime the excitement
of being near the water the sure strong
confidence in her father's
rough-and-tumble play the delicacy of
her castles in the sand and the
dreaminess and drowsiness and magic of
the day a lonely search for adventure a
shell a snail a starfish perhaps what
can a little girl find as her parents
sleep away at Sunday afternoon their sky
and Sun and sand and water and precious
little prizes she'll bring back when she
returns if she returns it was Memorial
Day with the first hint of the warmth of
the summer soon to follow
a car full of squirming impatient
teenagers wait for Jimmy Howell to join
them in their first day at the beach
[Music]
it's almost a routine a mother's gentle
reminder to her son to be careful and
her son somewhat less than gentle
disregard it's a wide open world and
he's been waiting to swim all winter
long so have all of them
[Music]
sure enough someone makes the suggestion
to race to the sandbar and everybody
follows come on in
water's fine last one ins a rotten egg
and then a familiar sound to kids of all
ages come on Jimmy you can do it don't
be chicken we're all gonna do it just a
moment's hesitation before he heads for
the water nobody's going to call him
chicken hey Jimmy yells wait for me it's
daring it's exciting and it's fun there
be lots of laughs out at the island when
Jimmy gets to the island
if Jimmy gets to the island and this is
Harry Johnson weekend fisherman you've
been watching his Saturday morning
ritual he drives down to the dock in his
station wagon it loads up his rowboat
then Heroes out to his favorite fishing
spot just around the bend in the bay
Harry's wife packs his lunch and makes
him a thermos of coffee every Saturday
morning looks as if there's no room for
that actually there rarely is Harry
doesn't like wearing a life preserver he
got it as a Christmas present from his
wife a few years back sort of a gag
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you see Harry doesn't swim a stroke he's
never been afraid of the water just
doesn't swim but he handles a boat with
the best of them just give him his
rowboat and fishing gear in his lunch
and coffee and Harry Johnson's at peace
with the world
as always Harry's pretty optimistic
about the day's catch matter of fact
he's counting on a fresh fish dinner
tonight when he returns if he returns
[Music]
unfortunately there are a lot of Julie's
and Jimmy's and Harry's for this summer
like every summer 100 million of us in
America will make our way to our
favorite swimming and boating areas and
this year like every year about 6,500 of
us won't come back next to automobile
accidents drowning is the leading cause
of accidental death between the ages of
5 and 24 drowning claims more lives each
year than influenza and most of these
lives could have been saved with a
better understanding of the basic rules
of water safety one of the most basic
rules in water safety is learned to swim
your local Red Cross why Boy Scouts and
Girl Scouts and community clubs offer
instruction
[Music]
swimming is a learned process and you're
never too old or too young to learn it
most drowning victims are people who can
swim only a few strokes 40% of those who
engage in watersports would probably
drown if their lives depended on
swimming fifty feet or more it makes a
lot of sense to learn to swim and
certainly the best time is when you're
young you don't have to be an expert in
fact whether or not you can swim
yourself you can teach your children a
healthy attitude and respect for the
water you can start by helping your
child become accustomed to playing in
the water without fear teach her to blow
bubbles and splash about and from there
it's easy to teach her to float
confidence is quickly built at any early
age and it is not done by forcing or
threatening no matter how comfortable
your children are in the water all
children especially preschoolers need
constant individual attention when they
are in or near water
[Music]
another basic water safety rule pertains
to swimmers even if you are a good
swimmer know your limitations the reason
for so many early summer drownings is
that people forget their swimming
muscles aren't in shape to do all they
could at the end of the summer take it
easy at first and gradually work up to
last year's level of course the safest
places to swim are where lifeguards are
on duty look for this sign and be sure
you obey all the rest wherever you swim
they're all there for a reason
never never swim along always swim with
a buddy whether you're an experienced
swimmer or a beginner accidents can
happen to anyone and they do a sudden
illness exhaustion a cramp a strong wave
may render any swimmer helpless nothing
quite compares to the enjoyment of being
out in a boat but even if you're a good
swimmer observe these three basic rules
of water safety enter small craft
sensibly be sure that there is one
preserver in the boat for each occupant
non swimmers should wear their life
preservers countless people drown each
year because they try to swim to shore
instead of hanging on to overturn boats
remember most boats don't sink when
overturned
unless your boat is drifting into
dangerous waters it's usually best to
hang on until help comes you're
struggling head isn't as visible in the
water as an overturned boat
[Music]
somehow the tragedy of drowning always
seems to start the same way a beautiful
summer day of family a few friends a
young couple plan a day at the beach
full of smiles and fun and pleasant
dreams
then somebody makes a mistake and the
dreams turn suddenly into nightmares it
happens almost 6,500 times a year needed
be so not at all for if we were to learn
the basic rules of water safety and
follow them closely these tragedies just
would not happen suppose the first rules
of water safety were second nature to
Julie's parents suppose they were given
another chance and instead of falling
asleep under their umbrella
they stayed awake watching Julie as they
should have been the lonesome walk in
search of adventure should never have
happened
quite possibly another adventure far
more exciting could have taken its place
under the watchful eyes of her father
Julie could have learned about the water
not to fear it but to respect it she
could have learned about keeping her
balance in the water how to put her head
in it without fear how to float maybe
even a few proud strokes on her own
and she should have learned that she
should never go in the water alone many
days of her life will be spent near the
water
and the more Julie learns about swimming
and feeling comfortable in the water the
more she will enjoy herself in the years
to come and a less chance she will have
of ever becoming a casualty of drowning
sure there are shells to collect and
interesting little animals to see by the
shore even more fun while daddy is there
to explain answer questions and hold her
hand
this is as a sunday should be and
suppose Jimmy when his moment of
decision came was more aware of a basic
rule of water safety even if you are a
swimmer know your limitations he should
have known for its every swimmers
responsibility to know not only what he
can do in the water but also what he
can't and Jimmy's friends should have
known that too the place for Jimmy that
Memorial Day was in the shallow water
where he could practice swimming safely
and build up his endurance even at that
he shouldn't have been long any time you
go in the water you should have someone
nearby it's impossible to predict where
or when you're going to need help never
swim along sure a few of the boys are
bound to tease Jimmy for a while but
he'll take it good naturedly and he'll
show them he may out swim them all in a
short while but even more important than
that he'll be alive to try
and Harry Johnson our nan swimming
weekend fishermen really should have
known better
[Music]
when a non swimmer enters a small craft
a canoe was sailboat a motorboat or a
rowboat
without a life preserver he's just
asking for trouble
[Applause]
it's very easy to put on a
life-preserver no extra effort at all
and certainly far safer
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you can never tell when a strong wave or
a sudden movement will turn over a small
boat
following a basic rule in water safety
Harry holds on to his boat it'll never
sink and waits for help and his boat is
much easier to spot in the water than
his bobbing head it's all very simple
when you know the rules
[Music]
[Applause]
maybe when the tragedy of foolishness is
realized 6500 people in our country
won't drown each year maybe when the
tragedy of foolishness is realized more
people will make it their business to
know the rules of water safety and teach
them to their children then and only
then those beautiful midsummer dreams
will stay as they are without turning
into nightmares
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the scenes you just saw are examples of
incidents that occur with alarming
frequency every summer almost 7,000
people drown in our country every year
nearly half of them youngsters now you
may feel that is merely a statistic but
think of it for a moment in terms of
your friends your loved ones and your
own family it's a little different isn't
it listen listen to me most of these
tragedies could easily be prevented if
you were to practice safe habits in and
around water and if you were to teach
them to your children of course the best
way for you to teach them is to set a
good example yourself this is your
responsibility there's only you to blame
if you're happy summertime dreams are
turned into nightmares I'll join in the
blueprint for life a program designed by
the Greater Cleveland Safety Council to
build for you and your family a healthy
happier summer in the year to come